aïe et il a vu l'avènement d'hitler en
allemagne donc il regardait l'union
soviétique comme un bastion anti
fasciste
l'un des éléments clés selon as
concernant philby
c'est que tout le monde a sous-estimé la
force de son engagement idéologique
l'autre chose qu'il ne faut pas oublier
à son sujet et qu'il avait des capacités
extraordinaires pour la tromperie
c'était un menteur tout à fait brillant
[Musique]
dre bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mercredi 9 février coup
d'envoi de la version française des
convois de la liberté des dizaines de
personnes sont parties de nice matin
suivi de bayonne perpignan direction
paris où ils sont attendus vendredi puis
bruxelles objectif protester contre les
restrictions sanitaires antico vide mais
pas seulement des gilets jaunes dont les
revendications portent sur les prix des
carburants notamment pris part à
l'initiative alors arrêtons à la veille
d'un mouvement de grande ampleur doit-on
craindre une grosse pagaille à la fin de
la semaine décryptage dans quelques
instants
le camp républicain aux états unis est
il en crise profonde les ténors du
congrès américain sont apparus plus
divisé que jamais ces dernières heures
en cause la façon de qualifier les
assauts du capitole du 6 janvier 2021 le
parti républicain parle d'expression
politique légitime quand deux élus de
son camp réfute ce terme et parle plutôt
d'insurrection violent qui ne sont
d'ailleurs été sanctionné un malaise
profond à quelques mois des législatives
de mi mandat
au sommaire à 21h la question de la
désindustrialisation de la france entre
1980 et 2010 le pays a perdu 2 millions
d'emplois industriels
emmanuel macron en a fait son cheval de
bataille avec la multiplication des
plans de relance économique dans notre
rubrique en pensent les français nous
irons à saint-claude dans le jura où le
maire se bat pour faire revenir des
entreprises la petite commune de 2000
habitants fait face à l'exode des
familles et appelle à l'aide le
gouvernement alors l'état at il
abandonné les territoires on attend vos
réactions sur notre compte télégramme
[Musique]
le convoi de la liberté made in france
at il vocation à prendre de l'ampleur
avant d'en débattre on s'arrête quelques
instants à l'origine de ce mouvement
venu du canada dans le centre d'ottawa
entre 400 et 500 camions occupent
toujours les rues pour s'opposer aux
mesures sanitaires une situation hors de
contrôle est surveillée de très près par
les états unis on y retrouve notre
correspondant thomas bonnet bonsoir
thomas alors cette mobilisation à ottawa
et ouvertement soutenu par plusieurs
personnalités américaines dont l'ex
président donald trump
ou c'est une mobilisation qui a trouvé
des relais chez des personnalités
influentes aux états unis assez
rapidement d'ailleurs parce que dès le
27 janvier dernier et l'aude musk
apporté publiquement son soutien à ce
mouvement canadien alors c'est une
mobilisation qui a un écho généralement
chez les opposants restrictions
sanitaires aux états unis principalement
à des républicains et vous l'avez dit
donald trump lui même a soutenu
l'initiative canadienne en souhaitant
même qu'elle soit transposée aux états
unis écouter
le convoi de la liberté manifestent
pacifiquement contre les décisions
strict du fou d'extrême gauche justin
trudeau qui a détruit le canada avec des
obligations insensé concernant le coc
vide maintenant heureusement le convoi
de la liberté pourrait se rendre à
washington avec des chauffeurs routiers
américains qui veulent protester contre
les mesures ridicules de bail donne sur
le co vide alors il est difficile à
l'heure actuelle de dire avec précision
si des événements similaires à celui du
canada vont se produire aux états unis
on parcourt les journalistes américains
et moi mais mon parcours depuis des
jours les réseaux sociaux les groupes
télégramme et une date semble avoir été
un retenu celle du 4 mars avec comme
point de rendez vous la californie alors
on verra l'éventuelle influence de cet
événement en tout cas beaucoup de
messages de personnes promettent un
soutien logistique alors le sujet s'est
même invité à la maison blanche il hier
lors de la conférence de presse de la
porte-parole james à qui un journaliste
de usc today a posé la question donc à
la porte parole en indiquant que des
blocages pourraient même se produire le
1er mars prochain à washington il faut
savoir que le 1er mars ce sera le jour
où joe biden doit prononcer son premier
discours annuel devant le congrès
américain jeu repose donc d'écouter cet
échange entre ce journaliste américain
et la porte parole de la maison blanche
comme vous le savez le convoi de
chauffeurs routiers à ottawa a provoqué
beaucoup de perturbations et à paralyser
des partis du centre ville est ce que la
maison blanche se prépare pour un convoi
similaire prévu à washington est ce que
la maison blanche est de quelques
inquiétudes au sujet de cette
manifestation qui pourrait se produire
dans la capitale
vous voulez dire en termes de sécurité
oui c'est quelque chose que vous
surveillez je dois vérifier avec notre
équipe chargée de la sécurité gérés paix
très simplement classée que les
obligations de vaccination fonctionne
nous n'avons pas vu de perturbations
liées à ses obligations dans
l'entreprise la mise en avant juin sont
celles liées à ses devoirs mais
maintenant quand monde a le droit de
manifester pacifiquement en soutient
totalement cela laisse est important de
noter d'où viennent les perturbations
voilà on comprend donc que washington
suit la situation au canada
attentivement il faut noter qu'un pont
reliant les deux pays est actuellement
bloqué par des chauffeurs routiers c'est
un point de passage primordial pour des
entreprises situées des deux côtés de la
frontière la maison blanche qui dit être
en contact avec l'administration
canadienne sur ce sujet merci thomas
bonnin en direct de washington on ne
sait pas si ce mouvement venu du canada
va arriver comme vous le dit et aux
états unis mais il arrive en tout cas
déjà en france avec le même objectif
dénoncer les restrictions sanitaires duo
covit 19 et pour se faire entendre les
participants entendent bien rejoindre
paris est perturbé la circulation dès
vendredi soir pour en parler on retrouve
emily goog h bonsoir emilie c'est au
départ de plusieurs villes françaises
que des convois sont donc partis dès ce
matin
bonsoir stéphanie absolument vous allez
le voir grâce à cette carte qui a été
publié sur la page facebook officielle
compte veille france officielle elle est
importante car elle elle montre que tout
a été méticuleusement organisé ce qu'on
voit ce sont donc tous les trajets prévu
depuis aujourd'hui il ya aussi des
villes étapes par exemple où passer la
nuit il faut savoir que les départs
n'ont pas lieu en même temps mais sur
trois jours avec donc plusieurs
itinéraires tout d'abord depuis les
villes les plus éloignés de la capitale
à savoir nice perpignan ou encore
bayonne ça c'était donc aujourd'hui
demain ce sera au tour des villes dites
à distance intermédiaire comme brest et
bordeaux et enfin vendredi les convois
au départ deux villes proches de paris
pourront donc partir notamment depuis
lille tours ou encore strasbourg par
exemple et le but est donc d'arriver à
paris dès vendredi soir et emilie est ce
qu'on va voir de gros camion bloqué la
capitale comme au canada
alors à priori stéphanie les images ne
seront peut-être pas aussi
impressionnante car en france les poids
lourds appartiennent rarement aux
chauffeurs eux mêmes mais plutôt à des
sociétés privées il risquerait donc
peut-être des amendes résultat on aura
sans doute plus tendance à avoir des
voitures ou encore des deux roues il y
aura bien sûr quelques camions c'est
certain pour ce qui est de la
mobilisation elle se veut plutôt forte à
en croire une page facebook intitulée le
convoi de la liberté qui compte ce soir
pas moins de trois cent seize mille
membres alors tous ne seront pas sur les
routes mais pour ceux qui soutiennent le
mouvement il s'agit de faire entendre
leurs règles aspiration face vous
l'avais dit aux restrictions sanitaires
et encore plus au pass vaccinale écoutez
justement ces manifestants qui sont
venus soutenir un convoi parti tout à
l'heure de bayonne on est en train de
soutenir le convoi des libertés
on a été tellement heureux de voir ce
qui se passait au canada et de voir ce
qui se passe maintenant en europe dans
le monde on vient soutenir tous ceux qui
vont partir pour une liberté il a fallu
être responsable moi je suis allé
travailler les trois confinement chez
attraper le coc vide au travail et voilà
et derrière ça arrange et à héros de la
nation maintenant je suis même plus un
citoyen donc je comprends pas comment on
est passés dollars à l'autre il demande
donc à pouvoir retrouver si la liberté
liberté face aux restrictions sanitaires
et notamment look on l'a dit face aux
passes vaccinale en particulier c'est
pour cette raison que les participants
au convoi compte donc rouler sur paris
ce week end et emilie justement comment
on réagit en particulier du côté de la
préfecture de police de paris ou encore
du côté des politiques
et bien c'est fanny ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que la préfecture de police de
paris suit cette mobilisation un
dispositif de détection de blocage des
accès à l'île de france et à la capitale
et un dispositif de verbalisation seront
bien sûr mis en place je cite la
préfecture de police interrogé par nos
confrères de france info autre réaction
celle du ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin selon lui aucun renseignement
ne laisse penser que la mobilisation
sera forte mais il assure tout de même
que les moyens seront importants pour
prévenir d'éventuels blocages et puis
enfin il ya la réaction de gabriélat tél
qui dit comprendre la lassitude des
français mais il explique aussi que nos
restrictions sont parmi les plus les
moins contraignantes et goûter
c'est qu'il ya une fatigue et une
fatigue et de lassitude des français
vis-à-vis de ce virus et des mesures que
nous avons dû prendre depuis le début de
cette crise pour protéger les français
il ya plus que quelques centaines de
milliers de personnes qui en ont marre
de cette épidémie qui en ont marre de
vivre avec ce virus depuis début de
cette crise en france comme partout dans
le monde
des mouvements politiques souvent
radicaux ont cherché à capitaliser sur
cette lassitude et cette fête et cette
fatigue pour essayer de créer des
mouvements moi ce que je veux rappeler
c'est que quand vous revenez quelques
semaines ou quelques mois en arrière la
france est probablement l'un des pays
d'europe qui a pris le moins de mesures
contraignantes le moins de mesures qui
entravent la liberté de ses concitoyens
ce sont bien les entraves à la liberté
que veut en tout cas dénoncé ce
mouvement qui n'a pas seulement atteint
la france si le premier point de chute
et donc paris dès ce vendredi les
convois la liberté compte ensuite
atteindre bruxelles dès lundi prochain
un mouvement donc qui s'exporte depuis
le canada et qui n'est pas sans rappeler
celui des gilets jaunes dont beaucoup de
membres soutiennent d'ailleurs ces
convois de la liberté merci emilie gogh
âge pour ces précisions alors évidemment
vous venez de le dire la question que
beaucoup se posent ce convoi de la
liberté prémices du retour des gilet
jaune le gouvernement a t-il raison de
craindre à nouveau mouvement d'ampleur
le débat est ouvert et on attend
évidemment aussi vos avis sur le comté d
g d'ayrté france et leurs dons de notre
décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau eric revel éditorialistes rt
france bonsoir eric merci d'être avec
nous à nos côtés également
nicolas vidal et nettoyer certes et
france vous aussi nicolas vidal à
bonsoir france qua tre boeuf délégué
départemental du modem dans le nord
bonsoir france 80 merci d'être là alors
nicolas vidal vous suivez ce mouvement
vous serez d'ailleurs demain au départ
de deux lions dans votre émission radio
d'ailleurs vous avez reçu aussi des
canadiens qui ont participé à ce
mouvement initial au canada comment vous
définiriez justement ce mouvement ben
oui c'est est venu ruiner c'est
extrêmement intéressant on avait suivi
et jaune bien sûr la passerelle peut se
faire et la question centrale que je me
pose mon recevant effectivement les
canadiens les québécois est maintenant
et porte-parole de combat france moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est l'aspect politique
c'est l'aspect populaire est la question
que je me pose depuis le début je ne
vous le cache pas je pense qu'elle est à
double niveau et surtout au niveau
supérieur à tout ça au delà des
restrictions sanitaires aux deux à cette
révolte là cette lassitude pour
reprendre les mots de gabriel talent ce
qui se pose comme question c'est
pourquoi ce qu'on veut la liberté se fit
il a deux mois la présidentielle parce
que on pourrait se dire les gens
pourraient attendre les deux mois et
finalement estimé qu'il faut changer de
prison république de gouvernement pourra
pour avoir des libérations de mesures
mais aujourd'hui je pense que la
question est beaucoup plus profonde que
ça pour moi le convoi des libertés au
delà de crise sanitaire c'est aussi la
faillie démocratique de la classe
politique pourquoi parce que la plupart
des partis politiques ont perdu quoi ils
ont perdu leur fonction tribunitienne
finalement de recueillir un suffrage
important est de porter des voix qui
sont d'ici d'hommes il entendu et ça ça
me semble extrêmement extrêmement
extrêmement important et finalement on
se rend compte que peut-être que les
français parce qu'il faut le dire
stéphanie mary les gens qui sont sur la
route ce soir on peu partout sur les
aires d'autoroutes et demain c'est la
partie immergée de l'iceberg selon eux
il ya beaucoup de gens qui les
soutiennent et nous on le voit dans les
réseaux nous avons dans les appels que
nous avons dans les informations que
nous avons il ya beaucoup de gens qui
peuvent pas monter à paris pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont du travail mais aussi
notons le parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'argent on ça coûte cher de monter à
paris v seloger touche donc surtout plus
mature et il ya le prix du bio carburant
on va vous redonner la parole évidemment
essayer de comprendre ce mouvement qui
est un petit peu nouveau en tout cas
peau pour nous eric revel il faut
s'attendre à un mouvement de grande
ampleur selon vous à l'instar de ce que
nous disait nicolas vidal il ya vraiment
une colère qui gronde il ya plusieurs
origines à ce mouvement potentiel il y a
on parlait de déficit démocratique est
le pass vaccinale b dont on sait qui va
être sans doute supprimés dans quelques
semaines juste avant évidemment
l'élection présidentielle mais il ya
aussi la question du pouvoir d'achat
globalement et en fait ce mouvement peut
se cristalliser autour de plusieurs
thèmes
celui des libertés très bien il savait
le convoi de liberté mais aussi celui
mais aussi celui du pouvoir d'achat et
ça c'est une thématique extrêmement
forte je pense la flambée du prix des
carburants n'a fait que s'accroître
ce cet écueil social pour le
gouvernement et je ne sais pas si le
mouvement va prendre ou ne va pas
prendre mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
pour l'instant ils s'invitent très
clairement dans la campagne
présidentielle d'ailleurs je ne pense
pas je n'imagine pas que le président de
la république se déclare candidat avant
de voir si ce mouvement prendra ou pas
de l'ampleur après il ya deux hypothèses
ce mouvement prend de l'ampleur et ça
devient un sujet politique de premier
plan pour le président la république qui
non seulement devra
proposer un projet mais devra aussi
expliquer son bilan et on termes de
pouvoir d'achat plusieurs rapports ont
montré que bon les plus riches étaient
plutôt enrichi en france mais que les
plus pauvres avaient décroché mais il ya
aussi une autre hypothèse c'est que si
ce mouvement prend
emmanuel macron candidat il aura besoin
de solidifier sa base et pour une partie
de sa base la fermeté peut-être un
driver important pour sa candidature
beaucoup de gens se disent mais cissé
passez moi l'expression de nouveau un
peu le bordel ex terra
l'économie française
le chef de l'état va être amoindrie on
peut voir les choses comme ça mais on
peut se dire aussi qu'une partie des
électorats d'emmanuel macro et des
français en général sont plutôt pour
l'ordre et la fermeté donc peut-être
opposera t-il comme il l'a fait avec les
débordements qu on a connu sur le monde
et gilet jaune il opposera à une
manifestation qui prendrait de l'ampleur
la fermeté pour assumer assuré son
statut de chef de l'état 150 avant on
parle également des conséquences
économiques parce qu'on a vu ces
cortèges ces blocages au canada là on
voit d'un oeil un petit peu circonspect
l'arrivée à paris ça ferait certainement
très mal à l'économie qui a déjà
beaucoup souffert si ce mouvement devait
prendre de l'ampleur en tant que membre
d'une certaine manière de la majorité à
ce que vous êtes un chievo
il est difficile de dire en l'état si
effectivement ces convois s'arrêteront à
paris il dans les déclarations que
certains ont fait est que j'ai eus y
compris sur votre site ils n'ont pas
l'intention de bloquer la capitale mais
plutôt de de la traverser pour se rendre
à bruxelles incidemment d'ailleurs c'est
l'occasion pour moi de souligner que les
peuples sont souvent en avance car
certaines leur leader puisque vous voyez
que c'est à bruxelles que dans un
mouvement européen
les protestataires se réunissent ce
pourrait être une leçon intéressante à
méditer pour les souverainistes
pour le reste j'ai trouvé des propos
tout à fait intéressant dans les deux
intervenants précédents je suis d'accord
avec le fait qu'il y a incontestablement
une crise démocratique et qu'il faut y
remédier et vous savez que le modem à
faire un certain nombre de propositions
et de l'ong là pour se faire
particulièrement le fait
qu'effectivement ça se produise dans la
campagne
présidentielle montre que malgré ce
moment de démocratie et bien il y un
somme de français qui ne se
reconnaissent pas de façon anticipée en
quelque sorte donc il faut vraiment s'en
préoccuper dans le résultat quel qu'il
soit au fond la question du pouvoir
d'achat qui wyss la centrale évidemment
et il faut absolument travailler sur
cette question du pouvoir d'achat des
classes populaires c'est très difficile
aujourd'hui de vous le dire ce qu'il va
se passer mais en tous les cas ce que
j'ai lu ce que j'ai entendu avant de
vous rejoindre sur ce plateau c'est que
pour l'instant tous les cas les
intentions sont tout à fait démocratique
une dernière chose qui est intéressante
monsieur ciotti a dit qu'il n'était pas
d'accord avec ces manifestations tandis
que monsieur coué tenace qui est
parlementaire de la france insoumise lui
appelle ses militants à y participer
encore une fois ce sont les populistes
qui tentent de semer le désordre contre
les valeurs démocratiques que nous
partageons même avec nos cieux sciatique
qui est un démocrate même s'il est
éloigné positions politiques et en a un
autre en tons kaki a pas l'air tellement
d'accord en tout cas qui qui ne minimise
pas et se met 6 1 c'est gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur je vous
propose de l'écouter
nous prenons les choses au sérieux ce
qui est certain c'est que nous mettons
les moyens de renseignement et d'action
si jamais des gens voulaient bloquer la
liberté des uns et des autres surtout en
accès à la capitale donc les moyens sont
importants la réponse de l'état sera
extrêmement ferme si c'est le cas les
policiers et les gendarmes sont très
mobilisés et nous prendrons nos
responsabilités pour ne jamais laisser
entraver la liberté de circulation voilà
on voit que les convoyeurs ans de
liberté sont prévenus par le ministre de
l'intérieur on a évidemment tous en tête
ces manifestations avec les jets les
jaunes qui ne se seront pas toujours
bien passé notamment à paris pourtant
comme on l'a dit ce mouvement n'appelle
pas à des actions de blocage ans est
très pacifique c'est plutôt bon enfant
d'après ce qu'on a pu lire pourquoi
cette ce discours d'affrontements du
gouvernement nicolas vidal selon vous
bien le gouvernement il n'a tiré aucun
enseignement de la crise et gilet jaune
le gouvernement doit tirer aucun
enseignement cheminement de la perte du
pouvoir d'achat la paupérisation de la
précarisation et ça c'est quand même
assez étonnant et d'ailleurs vous le
voyez bien gérald darmanin y parle de
quoi il parle de l'île de france et
paris nous voyons bien là la fracture
une nouvelle fois entre la france
périphérique la fronde il est jeune la
france qui au 4 du royaume de france et
de navarre et le pouvoir en place mais
entendu et vous avez raison de le noter
c'est francis sincèrement que ceux des
français aux français qui sont
actuellement sur les routes cj les
jeunes aussi qui sont là et des citoyens
lambda français moyen mais l'entente du
dont je fais partie ils n'ont aucune
aspiration révolutionnaire soyons très
clairs ils n'ont aucune aspiration
séditieuse ou factieuses donc je crois
qu'il faut toujours revenir à ça malgré
ses problèmes c'est la hauteur de 8 par
rapport à ça et moi ce qui m'inquiète
énormément et ça m'avait inquiété de la
ville et gilet jaune bien entendu je
connais bien ces mouvements c'est
vraiment la perte de confiance et la
perte surtout de la légitimité politique
et ça c'est gravissime parce que c'est
une fin dans notre démocratie si
aujourd'hui n'est pas résolu on voit que
la classe politique mais me regardez
monsieur philippot qui avait prévu lui
de faire qui a fait de grandes
manifestations finalement on voit que là
dessus il est même lui même il est
débordé finalement par ce mouvement
citoyen donc on voit bien qu'à une
fracture de plus en plus béantes une
alice est abyssal entre des millions de
français où des centaines de français
partie immergée de l'iceberg et la
classe politique
et ça c'est et le pouvoir en place ne
comprend toujours pas la situation admet
mme à 2 - la présidentielle qui sont ils
ces convoyeurs de la liberté on va
justement leur poser la question on va
leur donner la parole on est en direct
tout de suite avec régine briquet aux
retraités qui participent à ce qu'on
voit bonsoir madame merci de nous
apporter votre témoignage ce soir
pourquoi avoir rejoint le le mouvement
parce que nous avons été traités de sous
citoyens par le sumac roux avait montré
qu on n'est pas déçu sous citoyens je
voudrais déjà faire un rectificatif et
vous lire le comité officiel de koh voir
france ce sont les raisons pour
lesquelles nous allons nous mettre à
l'abri de paris ensuite ceux qui le
souhaitent pourront aller dans paris
pour rejoindre les manifestations où
qu'il soit puisque aura plusieurs
manifestations
le communiqué officiel
elle n'y en a pas d'autre et les
citoyens entendent récupérer leur
liberté leurs droits fondamentaux
l'accès inconditionnel aux soins à
l'éducation à la culture
le respect des valeurs essentielles de
notre constitution
stop aux sacrifices des enfants et de la
jeunesse ce sont-là maltraitances subies
quotidiennement vous voyez bien que
derrière ces revendications nous ne
parlons absolument pas de revendications
qu'on présentait les gilets jaunes
rémy notre responsable nicolas que j'ai
vu en vidéo il ya pas longtemps avec
maria et marisa il sait très bien que ce
mouvement est totalement pacifique et
apolitique
alors c'est vrai qu'un homme politique
qui à côté interne au responsable il a
dit on vous attend philippon a dit on
vous attend est la nôtre responsable a
bien répondu non c'est vous qui nous
rejoignent et de façon neutre il n'y a
aucune tendance politique dans ce convoi
régine les polos de messages pas de
tendance politique mais ce qui est
intéressant parce qu'aujourd'hui voilà
on s'est beaucoup posé la question ici
ou là de savoir si ce mouvement était un
nouveau mouvement des gilet jaune vous
dites maintenant nous ce sont nos
revendications ce que vous nous et de
nous lire le communiqué sauf que sur les
réseaux sociaux et bien il ya des
anciens gilet jaune qui se sont greffés
on va d'ailleurs certainement les
entendra ans les a déjà entendus
notamment sur les questions du pouvoir
d'achat ça bout vous n'êtes pas vraiment
d'accord ou ou tout simplement cesser un
mouvement qui semble peut être échappé
aux organisateurs et qui prend de
l'ampleur avec d'autres revendications
d'autres mécontentements
non c'est une confusion qu'il ya dans
les esprits parce qu'il est vrai que les
gens jaune se sont beaucoup battus mais
le but ce n'est pas les revendications
du gilet jaune même si elles sont
justifiées mais normalement il n'ya
aucune revendication et c'est vrai que
sur les réseaux il y à une confusion
c'est pour ça que j'ai tenu à vous lier
le communiqué officiel chaque personne
va à cette manifestation on va dire que
ça chaque personne
indépendante qui retrouve un ensemble de
personnes on parle pas politique du tout
mais ce sont politisées pardonnez moi
mais c'était tout simplement départ des
simples citoyens français qui parlait
pouvoir d'achat ça veut dire que ça a
été dévoyé selon vous et qu'ils se sont
un peu politisés vous réfutez leur
présence aujourd'hui
non je réside pas du tout leur présence
on est très contents qu'il soit là
évidemment il faut savoir que les médias
il faut moi je regarde tous les médias
et je passe mon temps à calmer a
rectifié sur les réseaux menthe
absolument / 7 / ont menti sur les
gilets jaunes pour les discréditer et
comme ils essayent de discréditer et ils
appellent déjà il annonce déjà les
manifestations mais je crois qu'à paris
ils s'attendent pas à cet événement
pacifique
on est un événement pacifique et non
politisée on va pas pouvoir empêcher les
banderoles on va pas pouvoir empêcher
des gens avec des revendications sur le
sur le pouvoir d'achat
ce n'est pas l'objectif principal
de cette manifestation
pacifique qui de demandes que le retour
aux libertés merci en tout cas régime
brique est de nous avoir apporté votre
témoignage des microbes elle c'est assez
intéressant puisque régime briquet ce
fait partie effectivement de l'origine
en tout cas en france de ce mouvement
plusieurs choses à retenir dans ce
qu'elle a dit oui plusieurs choses à
retenir ce mouvement se veut indépendant
de solides et gilet jaune ce qui est
assez étonnant c'est le moment où ça
arrive quand même parce que vous avez
sans doute entendu
olivier ferrand je crois ou le porte
parole du gouvernement expliqué que
d'ici quelques semaines on avait une
clause de revoyure et que sans doute le
pass vaccinale allait être mis de côté
donc si c'est juste sur la question des
libertés et des contraintes sanitaires
qui ont été imposées aux français on se
demande pourquoi quelques jours
peut-être à quelques semaines ce
mouvement prendrait une telle ampleur
moi je continue de penser qu'il peut y
avoir une une cristallisation très forte
mais juste sur le déficit démocratique
si vous me permettez stefan lippe tout à
l'heure le représentant du modem
pardonnez moi monsieur disait je suis
d'accord avec cette analyse un déficit
démocratique et nous au modem nous avons
proposé beaucoup de choses oui votre
leader françois bayrou a proposé
beaucoup de choses et je pense notamment
à la proportionnelle pour les élections
législatives qui suivront l'élection
présidentielle mais de toutes ces
propositions emmanuel macron dans la
tenue retenue aucune
34 ben fahd réponse vous le déplorez
j'imagine
oui je nous ne lâcherons pas nous
finirons bien par y arriver il faut
quand même dire aussi la vérité c'est
que les centristes sont ses seuls à
réclamer par exemple la proportionnelle
une grande partie de la gauche et plus
encore de la droite qui est hostile
depuis toujours donc nous ne serons pas
trop si monsieur revel est bien venu
dire ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il ya
une élection présidentielle et il ya des
élections législatives quoique ce que
quoique quoique va être le résultat de
l'élection présidentielle
il ya des législatives derrière et des
candidats qui seraient présents second
tour qui ferait des scores importants
qu'ils soient de l'extrême droite de la
droite nationale ou de l'extrême gauche
pour beaucoup de français ça apparaîtra
comme totalement anachronique voir comme
un un sujet de colère supplémentaires si
tous ces gens là toutes ces voix là
c'est millions de voix ne sont
représentés que par une poignée de
députés
alors on va pas c'est intéressant pas de
message mais c'est vrai que le débat
était davantage sur les convoyeurs de
liberté vous quand vous entendez madame
ricaine aulas nous dire mon goût c'est
sur les libertés
les gilets jaunes dont on a bien compris
effectivement qu'elle ne souhaitait pas
être récupéré entre guillemets mais
est-ce que selon vous ça comme on le
disait ça ne couvre pas une colère plus
grande on a vu que voilà envers et
contre tout et gilet jaune sont en train
de rejoindre ce mouvement on va en
parler d'ailleurs avec nicolas vidal
après
eric revel à raison évidemment
s'il s'agit uniquement des
revendications que cette dame a présenté
avec une conviction tout à fait sincère
au fond fin mars début avril le problème
serait réglé or il faut être réaliste
une grande partie des manifestants vont
manifester pour des raisons liées au
pouvoir d'achat et aux difficultés
sociales donc c'est aussi à celle tac il
faut répondre et il faut respecter leur
demande bien évidemment et je voudrais
répondre à cet égard à votre autre
éditorialiste il disait gérald darmanin
n'a pas compris il veut protéger paris
n'a pas compris que ça se passe en
province mais écoutez je serai la
semaine prochaine un jacut de la mer
charmante bourgade des côtes d'armor il
me semble improbable que les convois de
la liberté bloquent le centre de saint
jacut de la mer de sorte que évidemment
quand on pense à paris parce que les
convois se dit père paris s'il se
dirigeait vers saint je penserai à
saint-jacut-de-la-mer là ça n'est pas un
déni de reconnaissance de la province
quand on songe à l'endroit où se
dirigent ces convois nicolas vidal quand
vous avez entendu effectivement cette
dame nous parler de liberté
vous témoignez il n'y a pas que ce mot
d'ordre n'en déplaise peut-être aux
organisateurs i miss you de ce mouvement
qui peut être prendre l'ampleur et qui
les dépasse un petit peu mais vous avez
raison ce qui est intéressant de voir
c'est que pendant que nous corriger les
jeunes et j'ai fait plusieurs fois
l'expérience et pendant ce mouvement là
qui est en train de naître c'est toute
une partie de france est finalement qui
sont 60 senti citoyens ils sont
redevenus citoyens pourquoi ils seront
devenus citoyens parce que finalement
kong traite de sous-citoyens km annuels
macouin cette phrase terrible cette
violence verbale envers des millions de
gens il ya des gens aujourd'hui suivre
les yeux et qui se disent mais qu'est-ce
qui est être un citoyen et ça c'est
vraiment intéressant et je vous donnais
une année je regardais tout à l'heure de
libye les combats qui serait de même
j'ai un peu regardé et vous voyez que
finalement ça va très loin parce que si
vous regardez les marques des voitures
notamment sur le départ du convoi de
nice vous voyez que les marques de
voitures elles sont celles de cadres
supérieurs donc vous voyez bien que
finalement il ya eu un basculement de
violence d'herbes accueilli emmanuel
macron qui est inadmissible dire des
sous citoyens et il ya des gens qui se
sont réveillées donc ça fait deux vagues
entre les gilet jaune et cette crise
d'art il ya aussi ce basculement de gens
qui étaient les français mais qui était
pas qu'ils considéraient pas la vie
publique videmment comme importante est
aujourd'hui comme tout est politique
surtout ces mesures sanitaires ils sont
ils sont saisis de la question à
citoyenneté y aujourd'hui il monte
vraiment à paris ou d'un bout de chemin
et peut-être à bruxelles sas est
intéressant dans peut-être pas le temps
d'en parler mais c'est intéressant mais
finalement ce mouvement est très très
large parce que les gens se sont sentis
violente et ils se sont sentis abîmée
stéphanie sur cette notion de sous
citoyens et ça pour en chef de l'état
c'est très très grave il ya eu une
grosse polémique mais je pense qu'elle
aurait dû être encore plus massive
concrètement et aujourd'hui nous avons
ce qu'on veut la liberté aussi pour
reprendre la dignité la liberté et la
dignité voilà eric revel c'est vrai que
pourquoi de bruxelles on sait que
beaucoup de décisions se prennent à
bruxelles mais enfin quand on
manifestent contre les libertés c'est au
niveau national ça se fait on a entendu
d'ailleurs gabriela talent défendre son
bilan en disant voilà ça a été peut-être
moins pire que dans les autres pays
européens pourquoi bruxelles je pense
que c'est assez intéressant parce que
vous avez comme tout un camp
souverainiste en france qui défend
l'idée que nous basculons peu ou prou
dans une europe fédérale que les
français savent qu'on transpose des
directives bruxelloise dans les droits
nationaux donc dans le droit français et
ça me donne le sentiment mais il
faudrait les interroger que aujourd'hui
c'est ce convoi de la liberté qui
devrait donc se rendre à bruxelles
fait comme si en fait les décisions
n'étaient plus prises par les pays par
les états mais par la commission de
bruxelles donc c'est tout à fait humain
en prix c'est tout à fait intéressant
peut-être aussi que différents convois
parce que il se passe aussi à peu près
la même chose aux pays bas et dans le
pays peut-être que tous ces convois
veulent aussi convergé vers un point
central ils vont pas traversé tous les
pays et que bruxelles leur semble être
le centre de décision incontournable
mais c'est intéressant au moment où l'on
parle de de souveraineté face à une
europe fédérale de voir que ces gens
vont s'y rendre et quand même une
question qui est pas du tout cynique de
ma part mais on parle beaucoup de la
question du pouvoir d'achat et de
l'envolée des carburants il va quand
même falloir que tous ces gens m'aident
beaucoup d'essence dans leur voiture
s'ils veulent aller au bout de leur
convoi effectivement et ça risque de
coûter cher d'ailleurs je voudrais vous
faire écouter la réaction propose de
pouvoir d'achat et de carburant d'un
ancien gilet jaune pierre réagi à ce
mouvement deux convois de liberté on
écoute eric d'eau et
si macro est réélu je pense que les
gilet jaune ce sera encore pire que ce
qu'il ya eu il ya trois ans je soutiens
le convoi de la liberté mais je trouve
que c'est un petit peu léger au niveau
des revendications parce qu'il ya
tellement de choses qui ne vont pas en
ce moment plus que le pass sanitaires et
toutes ces choses là il y à l'essence
qui flambent plein d'augmentation plein
d'autres choses
la question du pouvoir d'achat
mais évidemment de la campagne
présidentielle vous l'affrontez
avec solidité pensez vous mais écoutez
je vous rappel pour celles et ceux qui
l'auraient oublié qu'avant la crise
donne le modem à plusieurs reprises
s'était élevée en se disant l'aide
sociale de la korité en disant qu'il
fait volume en une politique plus
sociale ensuite il y a eu évidemment le
solitaire et tout cela écarte mais il
est incontestable qu'il faudra si manuel
da cruz est réélu ce que ne tombe bien
évidemment mouvement démocrate il faudra
une politique sociale et il faudra
prendre en compte effectivement les
aspirations des classes populaires c'est
c'est bien évident
moi je vais être tout à fait objective
comme je me suis très souvent et tout le
temps c'est que
les français qui souvent montre du doigt
l'état trop dispendieux avec trop de
fonctionnaires ces mêmes français
imaginent que c'est l'état qui
imposerait aux entreprises une
augmentation des salaires or par
définition c'est la politique salariale
des entreprises alors il ya deux leviers
quand même pour l'état il ya évidemment
augmenter le point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires qui est gelé depuis
beaucoup d'années et puis la deuxième
possibilité c'est augmenter le niveau du
salaire minimum mais mais il ya deux
âmes ont avisé que écueil très fort
aujourd'hui si vous augmentez le salaire
minimum d'abord ça une répercussion sur
l'ensemble de la grille salariale de
l'entreprise et j'ajoute que nous sommes
dans une période d'inflation réel et
d'inflation sous jacente très importante
et que même si je n'ai pas du tout de
côté la question du pouvoir d'achat il
faut quand même s'interroger parce
qu'une augmentation généralisée des
salaires ça rend plus chères la
production et ça augmente l'inflation
donc l'impression qu'on pourrait avoir
avec une augmentation de son salaire
d'avoir davantage de pouvoir d'achat
peut-être rattrapé par une inflation
plus forte qui rognera au contraire
votre pouvoir d'achat l'occasion
évidemment de revenir sur ce thème du du
pouvoir d'achat très longuement pendant
cette campagne présidentielle et
notamment avec vous eric revel merci à
vous france à 4 boeuf nicolas vidal eric
revel d'avoir était avec nous pour ce
décryptage
et on parlait justement des prix du rang
et de pouvoir d'achat le pdg de total
energy promettent une remise de 5 euros
pour 50 litres d'essence dans les
stations-service des zones rurales un
coup de pub selon certains alors que le
groupe pétrolier doit publier demain des
profits records pour l'année 2000 21
estimé à 15 milliards d'euros nicolas
petit
depuis plusieurs mois la facture grimpe
la semaine dernière les prix des
carburants ont même atteint de nouveaux
records c'est dans ce contexte que total
energy a annoncé qu'un chèque de 100
euros serait attribuée à 200 milles
abonnés au gaz en situation de précarité
le pdg du groupe pétrolier français
patrick pouyanné a également décidé
d'effectuer une remise à la pompe dans
ses stations situées en zone rurale à la
caisse les clients verront une déduction
d'un montant de 5 euros pour 50 litres 2
euros pour 20 litres et ça dans les 1150
stations rurales de total énergie et
pendant trois mois mais d'après le
président de l'association familles
rurales cette mesure de soutien n'est je
cite pas du tout la solution à la crise
tant mieux pour les clients de total qui
pourront peut-être bénéficier de cette
mesure mais c'est plutôt une mesure de
communication un coup de pub nous ce
qu'on demande ce sont des mesures sur le
long terme il faut déjà remettre les
services qui ces dernières années ont
disparu il faut rapprocher l'école il
faut rapprocher des services il faut
aussi investir sur le long terme sur des
voies de chemin de fer sur une
alternative à la voiture individuelle
remettre des lignes de bus des lignes de
chemin de fer du côté de l'opposition là
aussi ces annonces sont perçues comme un
écran de fumée à la veille de la
publication des résultats du groupe pour
l'année 2000 21
le bénéfice net de total et de monsieur
puyané ces 15 milliards d'euros cette
année sur le dos des françaises et des
français les factures de gaz et
d'essence qui augmente c'est au profit
des actionnaires comme au moyen-age les
seigneurs balancent leurs miettes depuis
les tours de leur château stop total se
goinfrent avec 15 milliards d'euros de
bénéfices qu'il renonce à verser des
dividendes cette année et allège la
facture des français
total n'est pas un cas isolé puisque
pour les géants pétroliers la page de la
crise sanitaire semble définitivement
tournée les groupe britannique bp et
shell ont d'ores et déjà annoncé
d'importants bénéfices des chiffres
stratosphériques qui suscite la
controverse puisqu'ils ont un lien
direct avec la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
des ménages pour y remédier certains
candidats comme jean luc mélenchon
propose de bloquer les prix des
carburants
et aux états unis les ténors
républicains du congrès américain plus
divisés que jamais sur l'assaut du
capitole le parti républicain décidé de
qualifier les événements du 6 janvier
dernier en fin 2021 même comme
d'expression politique légitime et à
sanctionner politiquement deux élus de
son camp ont les chaînés et adamakis une
guerre qui enquête sur le rôle de donald
trump dans cette affaire comme d'autres
sénateurs républicains mitch mcconnell
le patron la minorité républicaine au
sénat a fait part de son désaccord avec
ses décisions
laissez moi vous donner mon point de vue
sur ce qui s'est passé le 6 janvier nous
étions là nous avons vu ce qui s'est
passé il s'agissait d'une insurrection
violente
dans le but d'essayer d'empêcher le
transfert pacifique du pouvoir d'une
administration à l'autre après une
élection légitimement certifier c'est ce
que c'était
ce qui concerne la suggestion selon
laquelle le congrès du parti devrait
être chargé de choisir les républicains
qu'il convient de soutenir pour le le
point de vue traditionnel des comités
nationaux des parents et que nous
soutenons tous les membres de notre
parti quelle que soit leur position sur
certaines questions
cette asu du capitole qui a donc eu lieu
le 6 janvier 2021 marqué les esprits du
monde entier des militants pro trump
avait pénétré au sein des dix fils pour
dénoncer l'élection de joe biden retour
sur cette journée avec yamina mend à
des milliers de partisans de donald
trump prennent d'assaut le siège du
parlement américain leur objectif
bloquer l'élection du démocrate joe
biden sur le point d'être validé par les
élus à l'intérieur une attaque violente
immortalisé par des images qui ont fait
le tour du monde conséquence de nombreux
dégâts matériels et un lourd bilan
humain avec cinq morts et des dizaines
de blessés plus tôt dans la journée
donald trump avait prononcé un discours
offensif devant ses sympathisants il
accusé notamment les démocrates de lui
avoir volé l'élection présidentielle
nous n'abandonnerons jamais nous ne
céderons jamais ça n'arrivera pas on ne
sait pas quand il ya un vol
[Applaudissements]
après la clôture des votes le camp
républicain avait lancé plusieurs
procédures juridiques pour contester les
résultats au sein de certains états clés
face à l'échec de ces recours une partie
des partisans de trump ont décidé d'agir
le 6 janvier ce jour là le vice
président mike pence avait convoqué les
deux chambres du congrès pour certifier
la victoire de joe biden un vote que
l'ancien président avait directement
évoqué dans son discours
nous allons y aller que ceux qui le
veulent mais je pense qu'ici même nous
allons descendre au capitole et nous
allons encourager qui aux courageux
sénateurs et membres du congrès
des proto qui aurait largement influencé
des assaillants du capitole à en croire
le président démocrate techart
notre démocratie vite en ce moment une
agression sans précédent qui ne
ressemble à rien de ce que nous avons vu
dans les temps modernes
menacer la sécurité des élus ce n'est
pas à manifester c'est une insurrection
depuis plus de sept cent vingt individus
ont été inculpés pour avoir participé à
ce coup de force plusieurs peines ont
été prononcées mais des centaines de
suspects sont toujours recherchés
la commission d'enquêté chargée de faire
la lumière sur cet événement a déjà
auditionné plus de 300 personnes mais se
heurte au refus de coopérer deux proches
de l'ancien président
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis houston aux états unis avec dave
perkins analyste politique partisan de
donald trump c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soit
[Musique]
bon ce soir dave perkins merci d'être
avec nous le parti républicain est il en
train de se fracturer sur ces événements
sur cet événement qui date maintenant
d'il ya un an die perkins
ce que la jeunesse correct serait de
dire que ce conflit révèle ce qui t as
pas de vrais républicains ce qui m'a
soutenu de la crainte que parce qu'il
était le chef du parti républicain s'est
gentiment toujours voulu du mal et qui
ont maintenant l'opportunité
de l'attaqué alors qu'il se trouve dans
une position de faiblesse au niveau de
l'autorité sans
risquer de conséquence couru en tout cas
c'est ce qu'il pense je pense que les
élections à venir vont leur faire
comprendre que ce n'est pas le cas et je
dois maintenant inclure which mcconnell
et le sénateur 8 macro ni où la
sénatrice makowsky ainsi que de membres
du congrès comme le making of est lisse
szczesny ce sont des gens qui se sont
efforcés de faire du mal à donald trump
a à entraver son allié politique et ils
vont se rendre compte que dans leur a
remis hier à des portes leur sont une
denrée car le soutien autour de donald
trump est encore très élevé aux états
unis destatis peut-être que certains
partis dirais que c'est donald trump qui
a pu causer du tort aux républicains
avec cet assaut en tout cas c'est la
thèse que certains républicains
défendent
avec un toit retour de l'assaut du
capital et j'utilisais de donner
l'assaut c'est que en vérité il
s'agissait du nouveau manifestations
pacifiques pour qu'ils ressemblent et
d'ici peu à de la violence il faut
vraiment tirer sur la corde pour
prétendre que c'était une manifestation
violente et certaines personnes qui ont
brisé par exemple des fenêtres au
capitole on peut très facilement
s'imaginer que c'était des infiltrés de
la gauche qu'au seuil est de rendre cet
événement du 6 janvier problématique
pour dol un train alors que son était
pas le cas fort cela fait un an et demi
de manifestations anti faé pll ou déjà
en doute et attaquent et tuent et
l'océan des imams ont été incendiées ou
des villes ont été détruites et pourtant
personne n'a jamais critiqué ces gens là
n'a jamais expliqué à quel point la
route et un méchant à quel point il
ajouté nombre et le port sur le parti
démocrate mais on parlait sans cesse
cette terrible et motte qui a dévasté un
washington situé ce n'est pas du tout le
cas le fait que des républicains
joignent aux démocrates dans cette
tentative devant un objet si
ces événements du 6 janvier comme des
émeutes en vidéo et bien c'est
républicain agissent contre donald trump
en pensant qu'ils nous posent en mesure
de tenir leur carrière politique tns
perkins c'est brebis galeuses c'est
j'ose dire au sein du parti ont été donc
sanctionné par ce dernier est ce qu'il
n'ya pas là un déni de démocratie
le parti dessinée et décider de son
programme quelle est sa plate forme et
si les membres le respecte est ce qu'il
faut faire si ce n'est pas le cas
je pense que le parti démocrate sera
bientôt et la même chose avec très
proprement nôtres vont abandonner cette
pluie et une
présentation
de récréation de masse
les informations ont fuité et les
démocrates se retrouvent qui le mauvais
côté de la barrière ils sont venus a
perdu le contrôle de l'état de virginie
et ils ont peur de perdre la maîtrise du
corps et les états unis auraient changé
d'avis et cru qu'ils changent d'avis en
premier vous contre le courant en
essayant de préserver leur carrière mais
je ne pense pas que cela va leur revenir
je pense que c'est les démocrates qui
resteront très longtemps accroché à
cette histoire fausses concernant le
virus qui vont souffrir
ou merci beaucoup d'efforts qu'ils
voulaient pas vous couper en pleine
phrase mais merci en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous pour re vu de l'extérieur
ce soir merci un beau
promis le soldat supplémentaire
occidentaux bientôt déployée aux portes
de l'ukraine déclaration aujourd'hui
d'un haut gradé américain basé en
allemagne pays allié aux états unis d'où
un attachement de plus un détachement de
plus d'une centaine de soldats étaient
transférés vers la roumanie membre de
l'otan depuis 2004 ses nouvelles troupes
rejoignent 900 autres militaires
américains qui stationnent déjà sur
place et
la mission importante de ses soldats et
de démontrer clairement notre engagement
fort envers nos alliés depuis leur
station avancé en roumanie une soldats
travailleront en étroite collaboration
avec les forces de nos partenaires du
pays hôte ensemble ils mèneront un
entraînement dur et réaliste ils
renforceront ainsi l'interopérabilité et
la confiance ensemble nous assurons nos
alliés nous dissuaderont nos adversaires
et nous nous tiendrons prêts à défendre
l'alliance de l'otan
l'allemagne la chute des réserves de gaz
inquiète des stocks tombés à 35% contre
82 pour cent l'année dernière à la même
période en plein hiver berlin subi les
conséquences du bras de fer entre moscou
et kiev plus de la moitié des
importations de gaz en allemagne
proviennent de russie
le rapport du ministère de l'économie et
du climat vient contredire des
déclarations un peu plus tôt du
chancelier chomsky assuré qu'il n'y
avait aucun risque de pénurie et pour en
parler nous sommes avec claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude blanchet
saison merci d'être avec nous tout
d'abord petite question c'est vrai qu'on
a vu la presse
alimenter un ce stress voilà les
réserves de gaz seront elles suffisantes
pour passer l'hiver en allemagne c'était
ce qu'on pouvait lire ici ou là est ce
qu'il ya une dramatisation ou est-ce que
la fiole sa raison de minimiser n'ont
rien vrai problème évidemment ce qui est
très surprenant c'est que les sociétés
qui sont responsables des réserves de
gaz n'est pas fait ce qu'elles font
d'habitude c'est à dire de reconstituer
les réserves de reconstituer les stocks
durant l'été elles ne l'ont pas fait
probablement parce que d'habitude les
cours du gaz baisse pendant l'été et
cette année ils n'ont pas baissé ils ont
continué d'augmenter parce que la
demande augmente et parce qu'ils avaient
un rebond économique et parce que
peut-être que l'offre n'augmentait pas
non plus pas parallèlement donc ils ont
voulu attendre en pensant que peut-être
le le prix du gaz allaient baisser or
les économistes se disent maintenant
qu'il ne baissera pas avant 2024 tout ça
est très étonnant parce que l'allemagne
qui est compliqué connu pour être très
précautionneuse et frdd et prendre des
mesures à l'avancé bien ne l'a pas fait
et peut-être que le gouvernement
allemand
réfléchira pour l'avenir à faire voter
une loi peut être une directive
européenne imposant des réserves de
garde il ya des lois dans les états qui
impose des réserves de pétrole parce que
ça c'est considéré comme stratégique et
pour faire circuler les véhicules y
compris les véhicules militaires
le gaz ça n'était pas considérée comme
stratégique corse allait maintenant
puisqu'on consomme de plus en plus
d'électricité et de plus en plus
électricité fabriqués à partir du gaz
par conséquent aujourd'hui il faudrait
en effet une obligation d'avoir des
réserves il se trouve que pour une fois
la france a été plus prévoyantes puisque
ces réserves sont pleines à 90% alors
quel impact cela pourrait avoir sur les
ailes membres dans ce contexte
évidemment de crise l'ukrainienne
effectivement les allemands vont être
obligés d'acheter du gaz cela dit il ya
un marché mondial de gaz ils vont
naturellement se tourner vers leur
fournisseur principal qui est la russie
la russie ça veut dire gazprom c'est
gazprom a un monopole d'exportation et
si gazprom pour une raison pour une
autre explique qu'elle n'a pas de
disponibilité de gaz suffisantes pour
les fournir à l'allemagne bien
l'allemagne se tournera vers d'autres
fournisseurs sur le marché mondial elle
a cette possibilité est là cette
possibilité bien entendu mais simplement
ça sera pauvre en plus cher puisque le
marché spot et pur plus élevé bien
entendu et que par ailleurs sur marché
mondial c'est du gnl de gaz naturel
liquéfié et ça n'est pas des gazoducs
bien sûr avec la russie à la proximité
géographique et les gazoducs avec les
autres pays il faut liquéfier le gaz le
même temps 20 méthaniers l'amener dans
un port allemand le regazéifié ça coûte
de l'argent alors avec un dossier
évidemment compliqué à gérer pour le
nouveau chancelier ou neuf soldats on
sait qu'il ya des divisions au sein de
la coalition justement par rapport
notamment à nord stream de la dépendance
au gaz russe allemand comment faire par
rapport à ce dossier j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya deux problèmes il ya le
problème à très court terme qui est de
reconstituer les réserves de gaz et
d'approvisionner en effet l'allemagne le
marché allemand le marché européen parce
que les pays sont interconnectés donc en
réalité c'est un problème aussi
européens au bout du compte et il faut
certainement donc reconstituer les
réserves acheter du gaz là où il y en a
de disponible si c'est en russie tant
mieux si ça n'est pas en russie il faut
en chercher ailleurs et puis il ya le
problème effectivement à moyen terme qui
est celui de la mise en service de nord
stream 2 mais non cm2 ne peut pas être
mise en service demain matin pourquoi
parceque il n'a pas reçu l'onction de
l'autorité de régulation allemande et
accessoirement de l'autorité de
régulation européennes et ça ne peut pas
se faire apparemment avant le mois de
mars ou avril ou d'avril parce qu'un
problème juridique c'est à dire que en
fonction des directives et des lois
existantes et bien il ne peut pas y
avoir une fourniture par un monopole en
l'occurrence gazprom et il faut gazprom
constitue une filiale de droit allemand
ce qu'ils sont en train de fermer ce qui
va prendre un petit peu de temps donc à
très court terme c'est un peu déconnecté
de la question ukrainienne
car en réalité
juridiquement il est probablement
impossible de penser que leur stream 2
puisse entrer en
fonction dans les jours dans les
semaines qui viennent mais il est clair
que la sphère ukrainienne aura une
influence parce que évidemment si la
sphère devait se gâtent et bien là on a
bien vu que la ministre des affaires
étrangères a fait valoir son point de
vue auprès du chancelier choles et que
maintenant la position allemande et la
position des états unis sont identiques
c'est à dire que s'il devait y avoir une
intervention militaire russe en ukraine
et bien ne rien y aurait plus de nord
stream de ce qui est d'ailleurs curieux
c'est que c'est monsieur bailon qu'il a
annoncé le progrès effectivement alors
rapidement aux clauses blanchemaison
alain pays aimerait bien jouer un rôle
un peut-être
le japon qui a annoncé mercredi qu'il
est livré à l'europe certaines de ses
importations de gaz naturel liquéfié
c'est un rôle sérieux que pourrait jouer
à le japon sur l'approvisionnement
d'énergie en europe il me semble que
c'est un rôle accessoire parce que il ya
quelqu'un qui veut vendre son gaz
naturel liquéfié depuis déjà un bon bout
de temps c'est c'est ce sont les états
unis d'amérique et c'était d'ailleurs
l'une des motivations qui faisaient que
donald trump était tellement hostile à
nord stream 2 c'est que kiel avancé
l'argument de la dépendance énergétique
vis-à-vis de la russie mais en réalité
ce qu'il voulait fêter vendre du gaz
liquéfié américain par conséquent les
américains sont là avec leurs qualités
fier pour autant qu'il y ait des ports
en europe qu'ils puissent regazéifié le
gaz de façon à ce qu'ils puissent être
utilisés en tant que tel et l'allemagne
manque de d'installation de ce genre
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison nous
avoir apporté votre éclairage rester
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de la désindustrialisation de
la france emmanuel macron en effet son
cheval de bataille avec la
multiplication des plans de relance
économique dans notre rubrique en
pensent les français nous irons à
saint-claude dans le jura où le maire se
bat pour faire revenir les petites
entreprises
[Musique]
vous avez bouleversé un peu les codes la
de la pâtisserie moi je sentais que
j'avais beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de créativité en moi
et qu'il allait être compliqué
d'attendre mon tour j'ai re questionner
en fait la pâtisserie quand on est chef
pâtissier ont nourris ont fait plaisir
là par la gourmandise par la beauté mais
on nourrit aussi donc pour moi le verbe
nourrir était pas assez bien respecté la
pâtisserie c'est le dessert que le
dessert c'est à la fin la carte la
légèreté est absolument à maîtriser
puisque on veut du coup un dessert fille
soit gourmand mais aussi très léger qui
viennent ponctuer un très bon dîner à
battre est pour moi c'est c'est beau
c'est bon et cela doit être également
sens parce que l'idée est le pari que je
fais c'est se faire plaisir en se
faisant du bien
[Musique]
paul biya cumule plus de 39 ans de
pouvoir à la tête du cameroun à quelles
sont ses intentions pour 2025 tout le
monde sait qui aura un après biya mais
tous ceux qui sont autour du président
biya fonds propre si ça n'existera
jamais qu'on a l'impression que la
direction de notre pays c'est un peu
comme l'onu tout le monde sait que ça
existe tout le monde sait qu'on est
membre mais personne n'y croit vraiment
au cameroun nous nous battons quorum
pour l'avènement de la démocratie alors
on associe le cameroun a à la
françafrique mais aussi à la corruption
je pense qu'on détourne plus d'argent
que le budget d'investissement de la
république par annick et chez nous nous
disons que le poisson pourrit par la
tête
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sent du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens
ne s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il ya quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
en 2010 il y avait environ 200
satellites en orbite en 2021 on en
compte quatre mille et en 2030 il y en
aura plus de 100 milles autour de la
terre le secteur spatial est un domaine
stratégique
où les plus grandes puissances se
livrent une guerre économique
territoriale et militaire essentiel de
laventure c'est pas tellement laventure
scientifique et c'est d'abord une
recherche de supériorité stratégique
rien n'est simple car les intérêts sont
divergents et la concurrence totale
[Musique]
les valeurs de la république doivent
être défendus quand certains jouent la
carte du séparatisme
[Musique]
les banques vont elles vraiment bien
pouvons-nous avoir confiance en elle
sonne au labrit et à quel point ce
sentiment d'insécurité que nous pouvons
tous avoir ré légitime aujourd'hui les
banques ne sont pas des endroits où on
est plus en sécurité qu'on ne l'était en
2007 peu importe la connerie que la
banque va faire personne ne sera jamais
puni si je gérais une entreprise d'une
taille comme grandes banques françaises
sans les nommer de la même manière on
m'aurait fait déposer deux mille ans
déjà depuis commandes à faire alors pour
protéger nos économies pour ce qu'ils
peuvent évidemment il faut dresser des
banques la risée mes parents ou d'autres
personnes qui ont dit milou 15000 euros
sur leur contrat ils vont où ils peuvent
aller acheter des delors elle est
achetée de une autre monnaie aujourd'hui
c'est eux des banques arisée banon pour
faire que les courses au super u il me
faut ma carte il me faut mon compte donc
sur la masse globale les tout petits
pourront pas bougé
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour cette
deuxième partie d'émission au sommaire
la question de la désindustrialisation
de la france entre 1980 et 2010 le pays
a perdu deux millions d'emplois
industriels emmanuel macron en a fait
son cheval de bataille avec à la
multiplication des plans de relance
économique dans notre rubrique en
pensent les français nous irons
justement à saint-claude dans le jura où
le maire se bat pour faire revenir les
entreprises l'état at il abandonné ses
territoires vous pouvez réagir sur le
conte télégramme verte et france
[Musique]
depuis 40 ans la france voit donc ses
industries plier bagages notamment dans
les petites communes conséquence des
familles sont poussés à partir pour
trouver du travail ailleurs illustration
à saint-claude dans le jura dans notre
rubrique en pensent les français nous
donnons la parole au maire de cette
commune de 2000 habitants un élu qui se
retrouve dans une situation intenable le
départ de sa population entraîne une
baisse des dotations alors que les
dépenses de c'est celle d'augmenter un
reportage signé renaud parquet et katia
technique je suis à saint claude dans la
capitale du haut jura qui se vide
progressivement de ses habitants ce qui
inquiète beaucoup le maire de cette
ville je vais à sa rencontre bonjour
jean louis millet alors vous êtes le
maire de saint claude à vis de vous
rencontrer en ce moment vous êtes dans
une situation très délicate oui nous
avons des soucis dus à une baisse de
population elle même due à une baisse de
l'activité économique
combien de personnes sont parties de 5
le puits de 1913 ans on est passé de
2000 de 12500 à
9300 habitants et nous sommes surtout
passer aujourd'hui en dessous du cap des
dix mille habitants ce qui nous prive de
subventions importantes notamment ce
qu'on appelle la dotation de solidarité
urbaine qui fait un million deux équipes
l'ont tout simplement le budget de
fonctionnement cela ajouté à 530 mille
euros de baisse de taxes foncières tout
ça aussi parce que les gens sont partis
de saint claude en avoisine les deux
millions de pertes de budgets de
fonctionnement sur 14 millions pour nous
la seule solution c'est de rapporter de
budget on demande à tous les services de
réduire de tous les côtés que ce soit
surtout les frais de fonctionnement déjà
d'une peur mais les gammes des frais
incompressibles
vous avez voulu me montrer ce pont que
se passe-t-il mais cet impôt qui a 125
ans il est en fin de vie il était très
fortement secoué par les crues quand on
rencontre tous les ans nous devons le
remplacer intégralement et c'est un
billet d'un million d'euros ce qui est
énorme pour nous et c'est très cher
heureusement l'état nous a assuré dans
une subvention qui devrait couvrir une
bonne partie de la dépense mais il reste
que nous devrons protée pour pour clore
le budget de ce remplacement vous avez
ici une ancienne usine de pipe qui est
fermé depuis peu d'ailleurs spécialité
je dirais même l'emblème de saint-claude
un l'école dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons vous allez devoir leur annoncer
qu'ils vont baisser le chauffage d'un
degré oui mais personnes vont mourir
ainsi sur un peu feront d'abord en
pull-over on sa vie un peu plus
chaudement donc je viens rassuré quand
même ils n'auront pas froid dans les
classes mais je crois que partout dans
le bureau dans tous les services on va
faire cet effort le coût de l'énergie
qui touche toutes les collectivités et
les particuliers et les entreprises mais
nous avons nos signer un nouvel appel
d'offres pour 3 en électricité avec 50 %
d'augmentation c'est absolument énorme
on doit faire la même chose pour le gaz
dans les mois qui viennent on va subir
la même punition et on va avoir un
budget qui passe dans les deux fois de
400 mille six cent mille x de gaz et
électricité et ça devient est
effectivement très compliqué il ya
beaucoup d'éléments qui font que les
prix aujourd'hui sont artificiellement
gonflés l'ouverture du marché
européen si l'on peut dire de tous et de
toutes ces fournitures qui sont
nécessaires à la vie de tous les jours
effectivement on en voit les
conséquences aujourd'hui et il va
falloir qu'on réfléchisse peut-être à
une nouvelle réglementation
ou renationalisation je sais pas mais il
ya un moment donné l'état ne peut pas
laisser faire les marchés qui sont
complètement erratiques et qu'ils sont
devenus fous
ça vous emmener jusqu'à la fonderie mbf
qui a malheureusement fermé elle vous
verrez bien petit peu la tristesse de
voir ces bâtiments qui n'ont plus
d'activité aujourd'hui
alors là nous sommes devant la fonderie
mbf qui a fermé ses portes il ya trois
mois vous aviez dit si mbf cool la ville
cool la fonderie c'est catastrophique
pour la ville c'est 280 emplois qui
disparaissent d'un seul coup c'est une
activité historique que pour la ville de
saint-claude et qu'il ya eu de très
beaux jours et là malheureusement c'est
dramatique
la perte d'emploi la perte salariés la
perte de savoir faire
tout ça concourt finalement
désindustrialisation qui nous fait mal
et pourtant une forte mobilisation mais
ça va servir ya pas eu de suite puisque
l'état n'a pas suivi en prêtant des
fonds pour une reprise la région a
financé un mois de salaire et puis ça
s'est arrêté là devant pourtant il ya
bien le plan france relance des manuels
macro est ce que ça vous aide parce que
apparemment l'enjeu pour la france est
de réindustrialiser mais une fine et oui
bien sûr bon il ya des entreprises
locales qui a été dit dans le cadre de
france relancée mais m'bia ne dit donc
de ce côté là on ne peut que s'en
féliciter mais pour ces sociétés
quittait l'entreprise phare de la ville
ben y'a rien on prend des coups les uns
après les autres ça n'en finit pas on
n'arrête pas de prendre des coups de
tous les côtés et un nombre donné bon se
dit ici
si le but c'est de faire crever la ville
même qu'on nous le dise tout de suite
quoi
alors monsieur le maire on a vu vos
difficultés qu est ce que vous espérez
pour la suite saisir pour la suite se
retrouver de l'emploi on s'active sur le
sujet nous avons des contacts avec des
entreprises sont des petites entreprises
mais petite entreprise deviendra grande
alors nous sommes nous sommes sur le
chantier voila je pense que c'est une
préoccupation quotidienne aujourd'hui et
puis parallèlement nous allons jouer au
maximum la carte touristique même si ça
ne compense pas la perte industriel mais
quand même c'est extrêmement important
mais je pense que ce canon un petit peu
assez de la vie dans les grandes villes
bien peuvent trouver leur bonheur chez
nous mais nous les invitons à venir nous
rejoindre et à y mener leur existence le
plus paisiblement possible et comme à
saintes odin plusieurs petites villes
souffrent des départs à répétition des
entreprises alors les gouvernements
successifs ont ils failli dans leur
mission de maintenir l'emploi en france
comment attirer à nouveau les industries
l'état at il abandonné ses territoires
on attend vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme et place à notre décryptage
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler loïc
prud'hommes députés elle est fille de
gironde bonsoir prud'hommes merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés jacques milliard
maire de maisons laffitte bonsoir
jacques myard merci d'être là où on
entend ce cri d'alarmé un poignant du
maire de saint claude 1 qui se bat comme
un beau diable obligé même de réduire
son chauffage à l'école pour faire des
économies la fota qui loïc prud'hommes à
la désindustrialisation
votre réaction après ce témoignage
écoutez je ne connais pas le maire de
saint claude mais je pense qu'ils posent
un diagnostic une analyse qui sont très
justes il part notamment de ces
politiques libérales qui année après
année soit disant devait permettre plus
de prospérité mais de libéral et
libertés il n'y a rien en fait tout ça
et est aliéné aux règles du marché et
règles du marché on le voit c'est la
concurrence de tous contre tous une
compétitivité au niveau du continent
européen tout entier est juste faire le
constat que quoi que l'on fasse il y
aura toujours quelqu'un pour produire
moins cher au plus allemand qui si on
pourrait le faire et donc c'est un
combat sans fin et vous pourrez faire
des plans en france relance autant que
vous en voudrez vous n'arriverez pas à
relocaliser d'une manière pérenne et
durable une industrie dans le pays en
fait ces règles de compétition qui songe
à dire sans foi ni loi qui autorise
cette question cette façon de faire et
du coup au coût des emplois
autant qu'on en crée autant on en perd
jacques mignard cette fonte de rien et
bf2 de saint-claude c'était évidemment
un outil industriel indispensable dans
un bassin d'emploi hyper sinistrés
cette entreprise il y en a plein
d'autres dans plein de village français
la faute à qui pour vous vous êtes
d'accord avec le diagnostic de loïc
prud'hommes la faute au libéralisme et
des associés au manque de volonté
politique
il y à un double phénomène qui a été
celui le dogme dogma de ces dernières
années il ya d'abord eu la purge
bruxelloise en matière il fallait
respecter les 3% sur les coupés dans le
fonctionnement et on a coupé dans les
investissements la france n'a pas
investi ces vingt dernières années à la
hauteur de ce qu'elle aurait dû faire
c'est une évidence ne sait pas les
marchés qui doivent gouverner c'est une
question de politique industrielle
d'investissement et la france n'a pas
investi peux vous dire qu'il ya deux ans
je regardais l'ensemble des dépenses
publiques sur 580 milliard c'est à dire
avec le budget la sécurité sociale il y
avait 2 %
d'investissement de l'état ça c'est le
premier point deuxième point c'est
l'aménagement du territoire parce que ce
mr vous l'a dit il tente de faire venir
des gens chez lui effectivement au lieu
de tout concentrer dans des régions
comme paris où on bétonne à longueur de
temps voir le rhône alpes il faut
retrouver l'aménagement du territoire et
faire venir des entreprises ce qui
signifie qu'il faut avoir le courage de
dire à bruxelles arrêter cette politique
stupide de tout concurrence pour
retrouver de la politique industrielle
et retrouvés l'aménagement du territoire
il vaut mieux créer et d les entreprises
à s'installer dans des villes comme
saint claude au lieu de faire venir
aujourd'hui
à vienne où ils auront beaucoup de
difficultés à se loger et ou en
concentrent toutes les difficultés donc
il faut changer radicalement monde
politique et j'espère que le débat des
présidentielles s'arracher de l'occasion
en tout cas c'est un aveu assez claire
de votre papa est assez honnête une
forme d'impuissance notamment face à la
politique de bruxelles votre réaction
logique plus d'homme parce que c'est
vrai que les gouvernements successifs de
droite de gauche comme de droite n'ont
pas fait mieux les uns des autres les
arrêter alors je sais pas mais moi qui
ai eu un gouvernement d'une gauche comme
moi je la représente récemment en
français
oui effectivement donc c'est un
gouvernement de gauche et des politiques
libérales et notamment la question de
l'absence de volonté politique notamment
quand on voit au niveau de l'union
européenne la façon dont on a libéralisé
par exemple le secteur des transports
qui permet à ce que les les industries
soit délocalisée dans des pays voisins
et puis que les produits finalement de
consommation reviennent ici pour
quelques euros de plus et puis sur la
question des fonderies parce que saint
claude est vraiment un exemple
intéressant moi j'étais au printemps
dernier aux fonderies du poitou qui en
sont en train de fermer puisque pour
quelques euros sur le carter d'un moteur
d'une voiture française un carter en alu
pour quelques euros sur des voitures à
plusieurs milliers d'euros les
fabricants vont délocaliser à l'autre
bout de l'europe pour pour gagner
quelques points de la marge et pour
servir quoi finalement pas pour servir
l'industrie de l'édition du pays pas
pour être utile aux consommateurs mais
pour verser des dividendes mais pour
assurer une rentabilité encore plus
importante aux capitaux donc ça c'est un
vrai souci et puis sur la question de
l'aménagement territoire je ne peux pas
ne pas mentionner aussi les décisions
politiques de ces derniers mois quand
vous avez ce gouvernement qui fait des
ponts d'or des tapis rouge à des
plateformes comme amazon au détriment
des tissus de petites entreprises de
moyenne entreprise ou en même de
d'industrie françaises on peut faire
tous les plans coeur de ville que l'on
veut si on permet en même temps de
développer c'est hyper plateforme à nos
portes dans nos villages aux portes de
nos métropoles et bien tous âges à dire
c'est une politique des shadoks quoi ça
ne vous dira rien on va brasser du vent
on va brasser de l'air mais ça ne créera
aucun emploi et ça ne permettra pas de
réindustrialiser durablement
notre pays on va regarder ces sources de
l'insee 1 qui nous donne un petit peu un
état des lieux à regarder les rockets
relocalisation sont désormais tout de
même plus nombreuses que les fermetures
d'usinés je vous laisse découvrir ce
graphique un nombre d usines fermées les
années
c'est voilà 87 nom d'organisation en
2021 c'est beaucoup plus que les années
précédentes
les crises sanitaires j'avais que mes
arrêts ce qu'elle a finalement suscité
une lueur d'espoir et 1 et surtout une
soif de changement on a réalisé beaucoup
de choses à cette occasion qu on était
peut-être un peu trop dépendant d'autres
contrées
côté malheureusement la pandémie n'a pas
aidé beaucoup parce que il est évident
que pour
reconquérir des des terrains perdu pour
mettre un aménagement du territoire
la pandémie a freiné justement ce moment
mais je voudrais insister mais bon quand
on s'est mis à fabriquer des masques
dans les
opérations chaque marque pas on n'a pas
bloqué des masques et des jeans on a
quand même
compris qu'on n'en avait pas et qu'il
fallait les fabriquer nous mêmes
attendez attendez attendez c'est pas
avec la fabrication des masques qui je
souhaite pas se terminer rapidement on
va réindustrialiser le pays pour être
sérieux ce qui se passe c'est qui est
effectivement le tout concurrence de
bruxelles a permis de concurrencer des
entreprises au sein même de l'union
européenne dont certaines dans certains
pays ont des monnaies sous-évaluées est
par exemple si vous prenez le cas de
l'allemagne elle fait fabriquer tout un
tas d'éléments de son industrie en
tchéquie et ensuite elle les réintègre
dans ces machines qu'elle exporte donc
elle gagne sur tous les tableaux un lan
monnaie sous-évaluée par rapport à sa
puissance de l art et intel des éléments
de son industrie fabriquer bakou par
exemple on tchéquie ou en pologne donc
ça ne peut pas marcher et c'est là où on
est les cocus de l'histoire parce que
aujourd'hui il faut pouvoir avoir une
concurrence loyale et non faussée il
faut avoir je dirais une monnaie
beaucoup plus adapté à ce qu'est notre
puissance industrielle ça ne veut pas
dire qu'on ne peut pas investir dans des
créneaux dans des niches et fabriqué
effectivement demain une industrie qui
montera mais il faut les aider ces
industries il faut mettre en place des
systèmes de financement pour
l'investissement en haut de bilan c'est
à dire prendre des participations pour
pouvoir aider le décollage de ces
entreprises donc c'est tout un ensemble
a changé parce que avant c'était le tout
marché c'était macron jupiter en disant
que les horloges le maître des horloges
ce sont les marchés non il faut
retrouver un ministre de l'industrie
avec de la prévision pour pouvoir
justement investi en grande concertation
dans les industries qui peuvent faire
décoller l'industrie française à nouveau
lui prudemment à la france insoumise
vous avez ce type de projet keynes aurez
vous les mesures en faveur de la
dalle et contre la désorganisation de la
france mais écoutez moi je bois du petit
lait puisque j'ai l'impression que
monsieur meyer finalement est devenu
insoumis parce que il s'aperçoit
effectivement que les politiques
libérales sont un échec mais oui
ap le toit de nos tarifs planification
très bien très bien donc oui la
planification il faut bien sûr le faire
mais je voudrais rajouter quand même une
de nos propositions et je pense que du
coup monsieur meyer l'a6 à s'y rallier
et c'est la question du protectionnisme
que nous proposons parce qu'il faut
effectivement un protectionnisme social
pour éviter qu'ils du dumping aux
anneaux porte sur ce que nous pouvons
produire ici vous parliez de
souveraineté ça ne pourra se faire qu'à
ce prix là et puis également la question
du deuil environnementales ou aussi on
voit produire notamment je prends un
produit alimentaire parce que la
réindustrialisation s'est aussi retrouvé
des tissus de production et
l'agriculture participe à recréer des
emplois c'est le protectionnisme
environnemental pour que des choses qui
ce que je disais tout à l'heure produite
plus salement que chez nous à côté d'eux
puisse pas rentrer librement ici donc un
protectionnisme pour arrêter ce camping
et la question de la fin des droits de
douane a provoqué cet effondrement
majeur de notre industrie en france
c'est évident tva sociale il faut une
tva sociale à l'entrée des produits sur
le territoire libre pratique de l'union
européenne c'est comme cela que l'on
pourra effectivement je dirais prélevés
sur des importations à bas coûts
fabriqués dans des pays où on traite mal
les ouvriers mal les cadres que l'on
pourra effectivement financer un autre
projet social ces du tout voiture
hybride missions et tâches ya davantage
de souverainisme
c'est davantage d'intelligence le
souverain se sépare un repli sur soi
c'est de regarder comment ça fonctionne
et domaine des écluses là où c'est
nécessaire maire de cabourg à chaque
fois était taché alors je voudrais vous
faire part porté par exemple aussi c'est
un c'est une escroquerie le travail des
tâches et oui mais ça à la faute à
l'europe jacques myard vous vous faisiez
partie des longtemps que je vous dis il
ya longtemps que je vous dise signé
effectivement non non non non mais le
problème moi vous savez je suis pas un
clown et je pense pas moi même je ne
vais pas chercher dans des slogans je
dirais deux parties et des appareils
la solution à nos problèmes ça fait 15
ans 20 ans que je dis que l'union
européenne va dans le mur eh bien on y
est vous n'aviez donc pas te dire signé
le traité européen de 2005
certainement pas j'ai voté contre j'ai
voté contre maastricht contre le traité
constitutionnel
elle compte lisbonne parce que ça ça a
été menée ce truc est une escroquerie
intellectuelle
alors on va découvrir une première
réaction tout de suite à la question de
savoir si
et à abandonner ses territoires
marionnaud dit de toute façon les
politiques viennent viennent que pendant
les campagnes présidentielles dans les
campagnes le reste du temps ils nous
ignorent loïc prud'hommes c'est vrai
qu'on les voit souvent des filets on se
souvient de marine le pen d' emmanuel
macron notamment lors d'un face à face
assez médiatisé chez les conti depuis
beaucoup d' usine ont fermé cette fois
ci est ce qu'on en a tiré les leçons
pour cette nouvelle campagne est ce que
les promesses seront tenues selon vous
ben nous en tout cas on veut se prémunir
des promesses non tenues parce que
notamment ont dit que les élus de la
france insoumise et dans notre sixième
république seront révocables s'ils ne
tiennent pas leurs promesses mais c'est
ce que je vous disais au tout début
c'est que finalement ça fait 30 ans 40
ans qu'on a des gouvernements libéraux
alors certains les ont appelées de
gauche mais moi je je récuse ce terme là
on n'a jamais essayé des gens un peu
sérieux un peu conséquents comme comme
jean luc mélenchon à la france un suivi
sur des questions de planification de
protectionnisme social environnemental
et donc le voyez je pense que là dessus
on a raison et monsieur mire le disais
et je le salue que quand on raisonne un
petit peu et que l'on se range pas
derrière des dogmes du libéralisme
on comprend que cette organisation
aujourd'hui des marchés est une faillite
absolue à tous les points et donc c'est
ça qu'il faut maintenant remettre à
l'endroit et oui un candidat sérieux qui
peut permettre de faire ce cette
bifurcation rapidement
5 milliard et maquereau a tout de même
fait de la réindustrialisation de la
france l'une de ses priorités en même si
pour l'instant le milan n'est guère
satisfaisant à vous entendre je vous
propose de regarder son plan justement
vous parliez de plans d'investissement
france 2030 avec ces différentes
propositions pour relancer l'économie
française crée de l'emploi c'est un plan
qui qui peut sauver notre industrie
selon vous écoutez ça vient bien tard
pourquoi voulez vous faire confiance à
quelqu'un qui a mené qui vient de perdre
en tête-à-queue à 180 degrés et qui a
mené pendant trois quatre ans une
politique exactement à l'opposé de ce
qu'il prône maintenant c'est pas sérieux
c'est là où la crédibilité du président
de la république est totalement ruiné
vous savez je vous dire une chose il
s'agit en fait de changer non seulement
en france mais de changer la machine
européenne et de remettre les politiques
au pouvoir
parce que ce qui est certain c'est qu'on
a vécu pendant 20 à 30 ans moi je vous
le dis parce que je me suis opposé au
sein même de mon parti à certaines
mesures et certaines politiques et je
leur ai dit en europe ils ont construit
une usine à gaz qui est en train de
s'écrouler donc il faut reprendre en
main tout cela il faut que la dg ac
inter c'est à dire là la fameuse
direction de la concurrence
intègre la politique industrielle
adapte ses règles et abandonne 2 to
concurrence accepte qu'on puisse aider
les entreprises pour s'installer dans
des villes comme saint claude afin
effectivement de ramener je dirais de
créer des emplois dans des villes à
taille humaine des villes à taille
humaine ça c'est important une chose est
sûre c'est que sans ça je serai en 2021
le pire déficit commercial de son
histoire 96 4 7 milliards d'euros je
vous propose d'écouter les explications
de bruno le maire -ministre de
l'économie
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a plus de 80
milliards d'euros de déficit il y à la
fracture énergétique et l'affaiblissent
port industriel des trente dernières
années
c'est le sujet que nous avons commencé à
redresser avec le président de la
république en créant un environnement
fiscal plus favorable en baissant les
impôts de production en formant et en
qualifiant les salariés à de nouveaux
métiers industriels loïc présente donc
le plan de métro emmanuel macron la
baisse des impôts de production votre
réponse il ya du bon quand même selon
vous mais c'est ce que je disais tout au
début en fait c'est une concurrence à la
fiscalité la plus basse est donc
finalement on est dans une espèce de
course à l'échalote sur celui qui
baissera le plus ses impôts pour essayer
d'attirer des investisseurs ou de re
créer de l'emploi mais je voulais 10 où
vous trouverez toujours moins cher
ailleurs aussi on veut faire concurrence
avec la roumanie c'est une course enfin
j'veux dire on n'y arrivera pas et je
suis absolument d'accord avec monsieur
meyer et je le dis de bonne grâce le
marché a failli là dessus et donc quand
je vous dis que moi il faut mettre des
mesures de protectionnisme fort sur ces
questions sociales c'est évident que
c'est la seule la seule façon de faire
et le plan et jeu une fois plus je
souscris aux propos de jacques meyer
c'est que c'est le président macron a
fait exactement le contraire pendant
cinq ans et aujourd'hui il nous vend un
plan de relance qui sera inopérant
puisqu'il ne veut pas revenir sur cette
question de la concurrence libre et non
faussée ou des marchés sont entièrement
ouvert joli du tout à l'heure il peut
pas en même temps faire des ponts d'or
amazon et à toutes ces grandes
multinationales et puis espérer sauver
nos pme avec des ddd plan de relance des
pseudo plan de relance non ça ne
fonctionne pas et ça ne fonctionnera
jamais donc voilà ça c'est une évidence
et je pense que les faits l'ont prouvé
par le passé et les mêmes les mêmes
remèdes prou les mêmes pseudo remettre
pro provoquant les mêmes effets c'est à
dire qu'il n'y aura rien à en termes de
réindustrialisation de création
d'emplois vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
d'un solde positif sur les
relocalisations
mais c'est quel type d'entreprise et
pour combien d'emplois c'est ça qu'il
faut regarder c'est le solde des emplois
et se solde des emplois il n'est pas
positif effectivement les emplois créés
ne compense pas ceux supprimés
d'ailleurs on peut le voir dans sur un
graphique ça veut dire jacques myard et
ce sera le le mot de la fin voilà on le
voit on pourrait supprimer ne compense
pas les emplois créés ne compense pas
ceux supprimés jacques myard il ya une
forme d'impuissance et ça sera le mot de
la fin notamment d'ordre c'est le
président de la république on l'a vu il
y avait peut-être une forme de sincérité
quand il s'est rendu à bridgestone dans
le nord pas de calais bien voilà on ne
vous fermera pas et c'est impossible
manifestement et qu'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est un problème d'investissement
c'est un problème de d'investir dans des
entreprises qui vont s'installer dans
des endroits où les gens sont beaucoup
plus heureux où il y a des j'm'en
sociaux vacants il faut le savoir donc
il est toujours plus du possible et je
dirais aisée d'aider les entreprises à
s'installer dans ces villes où il y a
une tradition industrielle que de faire
fuir les gens région parisienne où ils
ont connu des difficultés pour se loger
donc il est évident que de ce côté là
que ce soit monsieur law mer où monsieur
macron il est temps de leur dire beau
tête à queue permanent ça suffit merci
en tout cas à tous les deux jacques
myard et loïc prud'hommes heureusement
qu'on a appelée sans décryptage est pas
un face à face vous étiez parfaitement
d'accord qui l'eût cru merci à vous deux
en tout cas c'est la fin de cette
émission rendez vous dès demain pour un
nouveau numéro à 20 heures en attendant
l'actualité continue
[Musique]
paul biya cumule plus de 39 ans de
pouvoir à la tête du cameroun à quelles
sont ses intentions pour 2025 tout le
monde sait qui aura un après biya mais
tous ceux qui sont autour du président
biya font comme si ça n'existera jamais
on a l'impression que la direction de
notre pays c'est un peu comme l'onu tout
le monde sait que ça existe tout le
monde sait qu'on est membre